qui était claude erignac l'homme qui est
tombé sous les balles de deux individus
était un partisan du dialogue un préfet
arrivé il ya deux ans en corse un
parcours que nous retrace agnès
vahramian
7 est en avril 96 claude erignac
recevait la presse pour faire le point
après la mort d'un fonctionnaire du raid
en opérationne les journalistes locaux
le décrivent ce matin comme un homme
disponible pour eux ouverts au dialogue
pour tous
claude erignac était arrivé depuis deux
ans en corse sa mission mettre en place
la zone franche tenter de relancer
l'économie de l'île à l'agonie la
préfecture de région 10 et il est une
maison où l'on peut parler en toute
franchise certains se souviennent de
réunion houleuse mais aussi du travail
acharné de ce haut fonctionnaire à 60
ans claude erignac avait effectué toute
sa carrière dans les cabinets politiques
de la droite puis outre mer avant d'être
nommé préfet en métropole en corse il ne
semblait craindre personne le préfet se
promener sans escorte dans sa vie
publique comme dans sa vie privée une
protection rapprochée qu'il refusait ce
représentant de l'état avait confié
récemment à un journaliste qui
l'interrogeait sur la suite de sa
carrière je suis en corse et pour encore
longtemps